[Music]
let's go out to witch and talk to
Elizabeth what's up
Elizabeth yes what's
up hi um thank you for taking my call of
course
um um I was wondering how I can recover
from past trauma with my
son tell me what happened
um we my husband and I have I'm sorry
you're nous take your time take your
time you're
good um we've experienced a lot
of abusive sort of situations um
with her son um it got to the point
where um we have three other kids in our
home and um
we had to have
him removed from our home
um so sorry no you're okay take your
time was it be was it due to violence or
was it due to sexual predation like what
was it
violence is it adopted adopted son or
biological son he's my biological um I
had him with an abusive ex-husband
um and then my husband adopted him a few
years
ago how old is
he he's
11 do he a war of the state
now yes yeah as far as I
know what was the benefit of and this is
me not there's no judgment here at all
I'm being curious I'm just interested in
the procedural like the mechanics what
was the benefit of waving your parental
rights sending him over to the state
versus putting him in a boy's home or a
children's
home
um he's been in therapy and we've been
connected with multiple people um over
the last he he's been here since he was
four in Kansas and um where we're at
there just really isn't a whole lot um
and everything we were told by health
professionals and other people kind of
that were with us in our situation and
things
um everything that was said was that the
only option for those types of homes is
if he's a in state custody so
um that was kind of a
decision obviously we did not take
lightly
sure I don't um I've got some friends
that um run wetstone Boys Ranch in
Missouri in South
Missouri um but it's a place where
trouble boys go and they lived there for
a year um I don't the the the purpose is
always
reunification but here's what I want
like so that's that's all I know I know
I know about boys ranches and I was on
the board at Texas Boys Ranch like so I
get how that system works
this sounds like I've never heard of the
advice you were given but um that
doesn't mean it was wrong it sounds like
this may have been a very extreme
situation is that
fair yeah
okay
okay so I'll tell you I'm so
sorry thank
you I'm sorry for the hell that's been
your home sorry for the hell that was
your abusive relationship I'm sorry for
the dreams y'all had The Strain is put
on your marriage I'm sorry for this
little boy who's clearly got some major
major
struggles
yes
man I'm heartbroken for everybody I'm
heartbroken for this little boy I'm
heartbroken for y all my goodness so how
can I help
you
guess sorry you're okay take your time
you're okay
how do I how do I move on I
mean I don't think
it's I just don't
know I guess how
to help help myself help my family my
kids
um his brother brother is 10 years
old and his little sister's four um
while he Liv in the home and now she's
five and then my other daughter's one
um are they missing him or is there
relief in the home what what how are the
kids
responding initially during all of it um
they wanted him gone because they
thought they thought we would not
survive um
it got really really bad um to the point
where we had no choice sure um so here's
the deal I don't
um I'm not here to second guess your
choice
okay yeah my I'm here to sit with a
hurting
mama and I'm going to be honest I don't
know just step by step if your son had
passed away I would I would
know I would say here's what your next
steps are going to look like here's what
the next few years is going to look like
this one's a little bit different
because he's still out there
right
yeah and
um you know the care that you would have
given him and you also
know this exceeded my ability to
help
right yeah I just feel bad for giving up
I
know and
I want you to feel good that your other
three kids are
safe
yeah so I don't see a super smooth
step-by-step transition from where you
are to this
new Kumbaya reality for a while it's
going to be really
hard yeah did you make this decision
hand inand with some great mental health
professionals and some um
people who are in your
corner um yes um it's
just outside of our family and the
health professionals like at our church
and things um and work it's extremely
difficult
to explain the situation and then don't
they don't get a they don't get a
vote yeah it's just hard when like my my
in-laws they um they're incredible
people they're the pastor of my
husband's um there's a pastor of our
church that we go to
and um it's it's difficult for them
because and us too I mean when someone
asks oh how many children do you have or
how many grandchildren do you have
um so here's what here's what it is
here's what people don't have to here's
what you don't have to go into detail
about you don't have to go into detail
about custodial Arrangements you don't
have to go
into whose names on the whatever
list you can say my oldest son if
someone says how many kids you have you
can say four I have one son who's in um
a
home for boys who grew up with really
just overwhelming challenges as a young
kid w wow my gosh what happened that's
just not something I like to talk
about and that's it they don't have to
know the the custody Arrangements that
you signed over and all that stuff and
here's the
thing
um let's say he gets the treatment he
needs and there is a remarkable cure and
they find the right balance of
medication and work and therapy and all
of this stuff and he comes out at 18
and he'll be angry and frustrated and
you gave up on me and all that
stuff but if he's truly well and whole
when he's 23 24 25 he
may say
wow my mom was out of tools out of
options and when she couldn't sleep
knowing that I might go kill my brother
and sister in the middle of the
night she did what she had to
do
right
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so here's what I here's a couple
things I want you to do moveing forward
I want you to never ever say the word I
gave up on him because you
didn't
okay my guess is you probably went a
little bit too long is that
fair yeah yeah
probably yeah two don't try to wish this
away it's going to hurt for a while it's
going to hurt for a long
while and all of this brought up that
old crap from your previous marriage
right yes I mean my ex-husband left me
but it's like we've been living with the
10 times verion of him um for the
last eight years yeah oh
I want you
to make a regular practice of this
okay okay I want you to write a letter
to him maybe once a month maybe once a
week at the
beginning and just put it in a shoe
box okay and here's the fantasy okay and
by the way Pure Fantasy here the chances
of this happening are almost nil but
let's give it a
shot Let's Pretend he turns 25 one day
and is
functioning been through the system and
by then he's able to speak into Alexa
and AI finds you immediately and he gets
your
number and he calls and says Mom I don't
have
coffee imagine you're able to slide
across the table a shoe box full of
letters
and you're able to say even when I
couldn't take care of you even when I
couldn't hold you even when I couldn't
protect
you I gave you to the
people that
could I never stop loving you I never
stop thinking about
you and if brother and sisters ask
where's brother where's Big
Brother say he had to move away so he
could get all the help and care that he
need because he's very very
sick and he is a kind of sick that he
can't be
here because it's not safe for him and
it's not safe for all of us but man we
sure do miss him don't we I miss him
too and can I tell you something really
important it's important for them to see
you cry and it's important for them to
see you sad
yeah don't do that privately see me cry
a lot okay and tell them I'm Miss
brother I wish he wasn't sick I wish he
was allowed to be here but he's not
allowed to be here okay
and I don't want you to gloss over this
I want you and your husband every single
week at the beginning of the week sit
down and say hey how can I love you this
week where are you maybe he'll write him
letters and by the way in many ways this
might be a Fool's
errand and this might keep that wound
open for a long long time I just am of
the opinion that you can't close a wound
on a child like
this so I'd rather face that wound head
on then somehow pretend duct tape it
closed and pretend it's GNA go away
because I don't think it is I think in
the back of your mind you're always
going to wonder what's Bubba
doing how is he today I wonder what his
day is like
today so I'd rather head into that storm
than just continue to push it away and
push it away and push it away I also
tell you this that when families lose a
child when families go through this kind
of trauma it puts a unfathomable strain
on your
marriage so yall going to have to be
hyper intentional probably get some
marriage counseling probably connect
together this once a week week how are
you how are you he might be ready to
move on in two weeks and you might be
underwater in two
weeks both of youall are going to grieve
this differently and there's going to be
days that you feel so relieved he's gone
and then you're going to immediately
feel like a bad mom both of those are
true both of those are okay hold on that
you're a bad mom is not true it's not
true at all but the feelings are both
going to be valid
okay oh my gosh I hate this for you I
hate this for you hate this for you I'm
so
sorry if somebody listening has some
literature or some um I would love for
you to write in and
um uh you can email it to the show I'd
love to get some more information this
is one of the first times I've dealt
with State custody outside of some
really really traumatic mental health
disorders um but I'd love to read about
that um so if you have some literat on
that um and you can send it to the show
at john.com askk ask I would love that
um Elizabeth you call anytime call
anytime we'll be walking alongside
you